try to be honest with yourself ask
yourself this question are you happy
with the way did you are right now or do
you want to be great do you want to
improve yourself to be better some of
you might say well Daniel I don't really
have great talents or gifts to really
improve myself well stop believing those
lies in your head because there's always
things that you can do it requires zero
talent to be better and so in this video
I'm gonna give you 12 things that you
can start to do right now
[Music]
the first thing you can do is to change
your attitude I know life is not always
fair you can't control everything but
you can control your attitude
nobody likes a bad attitude it's like a
flat tire if you don't change it you'll
never go anywhere and if you change your
attitude but realize that the world
around you will also change
[Music]
good work ethic it's a lot of lazy
people in the world we'll never achieve
their goals why because it's always
easier to sleep late in the morning and
to press that snooze button it's always
easy to watch five episodes on Netflix
instead of just one hour good work ethic
doesn't require any talent but it sets
successful people apart from those who
fail honesty you know it's one of the
rarest things that you can find in this
world but everybody wants it but here's
the problem
you can't expect loyalty from someone if
you don't give them honesty be a man or
women of your word and then you'll earn
people's trust
kindness you know I don't care what
people do for a living or what kind of
success they have achieved in their life
it doesn't really impress me at all but
show me how they treat other people and
that'll tell me exactly who they are
[Music]
be on time you know I love Japanese
people because they are always on time
and it shows professionalism time is
life and when your time runs out so does
your life think about this if you're
running late you think why I'm just
running late 10 minutes 15 minutes
there's no big problem but you're
actually stealing 20 minutes from
somebody's life because you caused them
to wait for you for 20 minutes respect
first you got to respect yourself before
other people will respect you because
you know if you respect yourself then
you will also treat other people the way
you want them to treat you imagine the
world we would have lived in if people
started to do this passion whatever you
do do it with passion because it changes
everything even the way that you talk
take away my passion for example in this
video and this video will be a totally
different video very boring and it will
have no impact you get what I'm saying
if you're driven by our passion instead
of your paycheck you can achieve great
things
listen you know there's a reason why you
have two ears I'm only one mouth you mum
probably said this to you as well but
there's a reason for this when you
actually listen to people they will know
that you care about it and then your
relationships will improve and so will
you now think about this there are
always people who just talk talk talk
talk talk but if you always only talk
you only repeat what you already know
but if you listen then you learn new
things and you actually grow
humility everyone makes mistakes and
it's not always a bad thing because
making a mistake and then learning from
it being humble it's a lot better than
achieving some kind of great success
that makes you arrogant
nobody likes arrogant people CS Lewis
said true humility is not thinking less
of yourself it is thinking of yourself
less being prepared you know a lot of
problems that people experience in life
just come from being unprepared and then
people spend all that time and effort to
try and fix their problems but you can
prevent most problems if you are
prepared just do your research know your
options and always have a a B C and D
plan
do more don't always just do what is
expected of you do more you can always
do more than you think you can do more
than just help someone care for them the
more than just talk show it with your
actions
it doesn't matter what other people are
doing it matters what you are doing
[Music]
flexibility you need to be able to
change and adapt to different situations
in your life if you're one of those
people who are always stubborn or you
always hold on to your ego you know
those people who say no it's my way or
is the highway if you're one of those
people you need to know you will have a
very hard time in this life if you can't
adapt because life won't stay the same
it'll change I mean you can always stay
committed to your goals but you need to
be able to change and adapt your plans
to reach those goals if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and if you
haven't yet please subscribe so you
won't miss any of the next videos and
you might like one of these I'll see you
there cheers guys